yeah a new game against yard bird and
this is grandma's a LeBron ah not the
Kings gambit this time he has played the
Kings gambit against me numerous times
and frankly speaking you always somehow
recognize that he has got no idea about
this opening but he's a very good
technical player so we always had fun
okay so we've got a standard Roy here
and i'll play my trusted chigorin oops
okay yeah well Quincy seven is the
normal move to play after d4 after d3
you can put it on c7 it's not it's not
terrible but it's also not necessary
okay let's see what happens I want to
get get rid of the bishop am let's
exchange that so Queen takes a must so
9525 the next move so ah that's
interesting should I actually drop this
back to f6 or play Knight to f4
interesting question I'm not sure if I
go night FYI goes 95mm don't thing I
want to exchange on d5 probably just
just put it back so that i can play
Bishop e6 controlling d phi for a while
yep suppose the idea just just drop back
and play Bishop e6 next move so that um
I have some control over d5
just there should be six simplifying yes
but take is this really dangerous for me
i don't i don't really believe if let's
say let's let's capture capture here
we've got lots of exchanges damn i don't
think this should be a problem for me I
think I thought Queen 85 would be in a
porn are interesting
yeah while still hard to believe that
this should be worrisome for me some in
some way ok so how to continue maybe 97
tending Queen B 6 or not c5 something
like this the night is not greater ok he
probably wants to play before himself
what about 23 is this a problem maybe
should I play before yeah very
interesting questions here lots of
options queen bee three I can always go
g6 it's not the end of the world so
let's let's play this will have a nice
square on c5 anyway for the night I mean
hmm go get them not easy for both sides
how to improve here this bishop on c2
looks like it's a good piece but it can
it can be a problem in the long run this
is this piece because this part is on on
the light square and let's say an
internet game I can approach the spawn
Knight b6 a tacit it's not so easy why
shouldn't exchange too much and he's not
moving this irritates me okay only took
took a bit of time well g4 of course is
some not the rather committal move so
um
well Queen Quincy five doesn't really do
too much let's let's improve this night
should be should be okay they're also
takes away this d3 and d4 squares
maybe I can play Queen B 5 with the
tempo with the check yeah cash should be
ok and now take hear ya all this this
must must be a sub progress for me
everything else would would what
surprise so um Queen Queenie to tackle
the bishop and attending Queenie 5 also
most others the question is what is he
actually moving now
yeah this this pawn so it's Queenie 5 a
good idea also before hey I interesting
yeah I don't really believe i should i
should have any problems here but maybe
I have okay let's let's play it simple
if he takes before i take d 5 a day too
so at least upon not what i wanted to do
but so it's ok not sure I think he needs
to take why am i overlooking something
no I don't think so he needs to take I
attack be two anyway and the exchange
does justice a good end game for black
especially now that is played even
g-form yeah Quinn text before I only
move probably ok ok what do I know
obviously I needed to take this is a
mistake whatever this end game now is
just better for blood
and various ways you Ruby to coming d5
hanging so this looks like I really
should win this and he's very slow and
not not quite sure maybe he I don't know
had a coffee spill or something some
next morning accident always just
disgusted with this position might be at
really a really ugly okay so i can take
b3 and d5 but just let's keep this
position as it is it is such a great
structure i'll just activate here and
rely on on the good structure as
mentioned so take it mmm okay one now
but another shouldn't take it how do i
make progress i can get this to our form
okay yeah this is the typical thing that
often happens if you are sure that you
win on time you make some movement you
really spoil it this this peluche it
isn't it isn't so clear even because my
Lucas is in a in a bad spot
wait for it yeah well he was clear that
he would lose on time so I didn't really
look so so much yeah but that was bad i
should have really played better some of
this all keeps the advantage but maybe
maybe I really should should take it I
don't know it is a pawn but it's such a
shame to exchange this night against
this bloody bishop ok I keep an
advantage this is out of the question
maybe here maybe there here's something
I don't know take take maybe maybe some
some tactical thing this one maybe this
is actually really strong in it it seems
to seems to be really good before take
take i-95 is gone yeah this is what I
should have done shift taken on a three
yeah well thanks for watching this video
interesting game and win against the GMS
always noise thanks